so i noticed that you're a huge fan of
retro games
oh yeah and i i think we all grew up
these retro games
um i mean could you tell us some of your
favorite retro games i'm interested oh
was that too old the one i played most
was
sailor moon action game yeah really it's
very very
final fight-ish but is that the fighting
game
no it's actually action game so like you
get it's exactly like final fight you
just keep walking and some
are like oh like double dragon yeah yeah
we call in japanese the belt action
build score action game
right keep going
yeah i think uh i think my cousin like
had like a collection because there was
a number of them right there was like
six or seven of them on the uh at least
two
super farming games for action games and
one puzzle game
one rpg two fighting games
which game was even galleon game you
were streaming oh yeah ever
i played the first playstation ever game
that gave a game for playstation right
it was generation game
so you think like you choose a sudden
answer and that's going to change the
ending yeah but actually
until the very end nothing does it's
always the same
until the very end the final question
gonna let you choose three paths like
three endings right
nothing but everything else basically it
was basically just mass effect then
your choices mean nothing you know what
you can't even skip
any stories you have to re-watch it
again and again that is like conan's
worst nightmare that's my hell
i love like i love the old neo geo games
like metal slug is like my favorite
series
i recently just did a video where i went
and uh played a bunch of like
japan only retro games like anime retro
games um
like uh there was the because there's
like a number of like jojo games as well
like yeah
uh super famicom and like your game
game dude that you hosting it's so fun
but i didn't realize that it's a really
popular game
in japan but no one in the west knows
about it because
they only localized it well obviously
they only released in japan and for some
reason brazil
but only brazil like the us didn't get
it
europe didn't get it australia didn't
get it it was only brazil that goddess
there are maybe a lot of like japanese
brazilians at the time oh yeah there is
a
i i found this out today actually
because the professional wrestler like a
legendary professional wrestler
oh yeah yeah that makes sense that's
right yeah that's right yeah apparently
there's a huge
population of japanese in brazil i can't
remember the reason why but uh
well anime is like pretty big in brazil
so i've heard i mean way bigger than it
was
you know where where we grew up but it's
just it just amazes me how many anime
games there are that have just existed
that or just
never get translated yeah yeah even some
big ones still have not been translated
why because the sarah moon rpg one they
just got a thumbs up a few years ago
yeah after all those years the original
face day night visual novel has still
not been officially translated
really yeah yeah so you if anyone who's
played the original face day night
vision novel it's it's all fan
translations right now
and fake fans expect people to get
people into it by reading the visual
yeah because i know it was like really
massive news i think it was like three
years ago
when uh they decided to make an official
uh like english translation of the clan
ad visual novel and they'd made like a
kickstarter for it and everything and it
got finished in like less than 24 hours
even though it's such an old game
and and it wasn't at that point i
realized i'm like oh [ __ ] there's never
been an official translation of this
game it's all fan sobs
and in my head i'm just like who is
doing these fan stuff
who has so much time like you can
talent so many yeah and talent that
you're like you know what there's this
visual novel
that's all dialogue 200 plus hours long
it's probably like if you put into a
script it's like you know 300 400 pages
yeah i'm a translator how do you get
how do you find yourself in that
position weebs weaponized man
weebs are so passionate they are yeah
they are like what's uh
was it was it secret of manner that
never got an official
the first one yeah yeah yeah yeah final
fantasy never got released even though
it was a huge series
until very recently yeah until very
racially which is crazy to think a game
series like final fantasy that was
killing it in the west as well like then
one of them wasn't released
yeah yeah that's crazy it's really weird
i have a lot of
macros fanatic friends in california
especially
but i think the only official one was
robotech right
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't wanna you
have to look for them yeah
fishery it's hard being a weeb man oh
it's hard especially a
retro weeb because now like macross or
macros sorry
it's like it's it's not got as big of a
fan base as it used to because now mecca
has just kind of like
almost died in the like the western
fandom
it's only the very dedicated fans that
still keep up with everything like that
and if there is mecca then it's usually
combined with some other genre
that is more appealing right yeah it's
like it's it's not usually like mecca is
the main it's like
here is the main and we just add a
little bit of mecca to it i think like
the last big mecca was probably darling
in the franxx and i'm pretty sure
more people cared about zero two than
they cared about the max
no one was like oh darling in the frame
those meccas are cool like darling in
the franks
it was about the side
yeah that's all they cared about
we missed out on so many good porn
parodies japan because you're dumb laws
of darling in the franchise yeah oh my
god
i'm surprised they haven't made a
darling in the frank's pawn yet or in
fact
so many anime series or manga series
that could easily
make a porn parody and i know it will
sell
right all right well american porn
producers who listen to trash taste
please make it happen
hey man we just gave you guys like free
real estate yeah exactly right because
you know people are going to buy that
[ __ ] if they make it in the west
right yeah yeah